the laws which this science sets out to
find our relations between these two
supposed aspects and hence can
themselves be nothing more than empty
subjective opinions also since the
object of this supposed way of knowing
which takes it upon itself to deal with
the reality of spirit is just the
reflection of spirit out of its sensuous
existence back into itself in a
particular physical existence is for
spirit something indifferent and
contingent this kind of knowing must be
directly aware that the laws it has
discovered tell us nothing that's
strictly speaking it is idle chatter or
merely the voicing of one's own opinion
an expression which contains the truth
of about itself that is that it is one's
own opinion that is put forward hence
not the matter itself but merely an
opinion of one's own as regards their
content however these observations are
on par with these it always rains when
we have our annual fair says the dealer
and every time too says the housewife
when I am drying my washing
after having made what we could call a
good faith effort to to see whether one
of the pseudo-sciences of his own time
physiognomies he's also going to talk
about phrenology can actually make good
on its promises and follow out it's the
sort of the current or the implications
of its premises hagel now is a bet on
the attack but he's going even further
on the attack he is going to isolate
something that turns out to be very
important and and is going to show up in
some of the other passages following
this so the question is whether anything
like a real law something that provides
intelligibility regularity and
understanding of the relationship
between cause and a factor in this case
what is being expressed and its
expression in living human beings in
enacting subjects whether anything like
that is really provided by physiognomies
and the answer of course is no but why
is the answer no that's where we get to
something more interesting so he says
the laws that this science sets out to
find would be relations between these
two supposed aspects right so we're not
getting anything like what physiognomies
purporting to provide us with which is
the relationship between the inner and
the outer a relationship that actually
works its way backwards because we
observe the outer and we draw
conclusions from that outer about the
inner of a given person or a class of
people a lot of notions of race
prevalent at the time where we're
drawing upon this this sort of
conception class also fits in with this
oftentimes race and class would get
conflated in very sloppy ways we can now
recognize and what's really going on
here so Hagel put
finger at it he says what we have here
are really nothing more than empty
subjective opinions now notice the term
that's being translated here as opinion
is mining this is something that we
encountered already back in the
consciousness section when we saw that
there is a distinction between the
mining or intending or trying to say
something and it's always got a sort of
connotation of you know individuality or
particular particularity or your subject
hitting and what was actually Universal
the you know could be language right
language you try to make up a word that
that you know expresses exactly what you
want well if you make up a word and
nobody else expresses things using that
word the word is totally worthless right
you may as well be doing a gesture here
we don't even have a gesture we have
something of the outward form that is
being used and what's connecting them
together is as Hagel sang empty
subjective opinion whose opinion the
opinion of the person engaging in
physiognomies it's kind of made up ad
hoc by drawing conclusions making
inferences that are ultimately going to
be based on opinion like the ones that
he finishes up with saying they're on a
par these observations with these sorts
of observations the dealer says it
always rains when we have our annual
fair and then the housewife responds and
every time to when I'm drying my washing
now you know what's the implication does
it really rain every time that they have
their annual fair no the person is
saying something that may have some sort
of basis in their experience but they're
drawing some pretty unfounded
conclusions from them the housewife is
also getting involved in it because it's
fun to express oneself it's fun to
connect things together even if there
isn't a
connection there and so she says yeah
every time that I do my wash it rains
because you know you have to do your
wash outside and also hang your stuff to
dry outside now this is uh this is very
problematic so he goes on and he says
the object of this supposed way of
knowing which takes upon itself to deal
with the reality of spirit that's what
law is supposed to be providing us with
here because we're not talking about
laws of electricity or organic life as
such we're talking about laws that
pertain to human beings as human beings
as agents as things that have an
interior side to them and which express
themselves through their bodies in
externalize ations of some sort the
question is well what sort of external
ization should we be looking at we're
looking to so he goes on and he says
because this is supposed to deal with
the reality of spirit it's just the
reflection of spirit out of its sensuous
existence back into itself and a
particular physical existence is for
spirit something and different and
contingent what are we talking about
their well any given body is something
contingent so if we're looking at the
outer and we're looking at maybe ten
outers right yeah think about this if
we're drawing conclusions based on the
physiognomies or you know there's other
ways of doing that as well based on the
outward shape or form or configuration
or perhaps you know I might even say the
genetics of just a few people how much
can we really conclude from that are we
going too far when we draw fairly
sweeping conclusions based on that
that's a good question so he goes on and
he says because of this this kind of
knowing must be directly aware that the
laws it is discovered tell us nothing so
they're not really laws at all they're
not providing us with what laws are
supposed to provide
with he says strictly speaking it
becomes idle chatter it becomes the sort
of thing that people just say you know
around the proverbial water cooler not
too many businesses have water coolers
these days well you get the idea they
sit in the coffee shop and people
chatter about you know mankind and
politics and what people you know of
this sort do and what people of that
sort do and they draw sweeping
conclusions that can't really be
supported and they do it based on
people's appearance their body their
face so he goes on and he says it's idle
chatter or merely the voicing of one's
own opinion and we ought to think about
what Hagel has to say here in our
culture we often get the message that
our opinion matters because it's our
opinion right and everybody has opinions
we also get the message that opinions
are like a certain part of our body
everybody's got them and something often
comes out of them right but all too
often we get told that our opinion
matters because it is our opinion Hagel
says no no not at all your opinion
matters if it's expressing something
that's connected in some way with the
universal it doesn't have to be
necessarily universal as such but it
better be more than just your mere
opinion or else what are you doing
you're asserting yourself over against
other subjectivity and saying that they
want to see things the way that you do
they ought to believe in these laws
because you've drawn a few conclusions
in your idle chatter about what
somebody's appearance is and what that
has to say about them and then you go on
and generalize about other people all
the criminal type you know I can tell
them by looking at them oh I can tell
that that person is is you know
promiscuous and likely to cheat by the
way that they appear well you don't
actually know much of anything if you're
drawing it from just a few circumstances
even if you have a case where that
person was a cheater and they looked a
certain way right this is this is one of
the fundamental problem so he says
what does one's own opinion tell us it
contains the truth of itself in that
expression that it is one's own opinion
that is put forward not the matter
itself but merely an opinion of one's
own and so we get to these things like
oh it always rains when the fair is on
it always rains too and I'm doing my
wash these generalizations are not even
real generalizations and so we have to
be very careful in talking about
appearance and what that indicates to us
about human being
lichtenberg who characterizes
physiognomic observation in this way
also says this if anyone said you
certainly act like an honest man but I
see from your face that you are forcing
yourself to do so and our row get hurt
without a doubt every honest fellow to
the end of time when the sad rest will
retort with a box on the ear this retort
is to the point because it refutes the
primary assumption of such a science of
mere subjective opinion that is that the
reality of a man is his face and so on
the true being of a man is rather his
deed in this the individual is actual
and is it is the deed that does away
with both aspects of what is merely
meant to be in the one aspect where what
is meant has the form of a corporeal
passive being the individuality and the
deed exhibits itself rather as the
negative essence which only is insofar
as it supersedes mere being then to the
deed equally does away with the inn
express ability of what is meant in
respect to the self-conscious
individuality in such mere opinion the
individuality is infinitely determined
and determinable in the accomplished
deed this spurious infinity is destroyed
the deed is something simply determined
Universal to be grasped in an
abstraction it is murder theft or a good
action a brave deed and so on and what
what it is can be said of it it is this
and it's being is not merely a sign but
the fact itself it is this and the
individual human being is what the deed
is in the simplicity of this being the
individual is for others a universal
being who really is and who ceases to be
something only met it is true that in
the deed he is not explicitly present as
spirit but when it is a question of his
being qua being and on the one hand when
the twofold being a bodily shape and
Dean are contrasted each purporting to
be what he actually is then it is the
deed alone that must be affirmed as his
genuine being not his face her outward
appearance which is supposed to express
what he means
by his deeds or what anyone might
suppose he merely could do similarly on
the other hand when his performance in
his inner possibility capacity or
intention are contrasted it is the
former alone which is to be regarded as
his true actuality even if he deceives
himself on the point and turning away
from his action into himself fancies
that in this inner self he is something
else than what he is in the deed
individuality when it commits itself to
the objective element and putting itself
into a deed does of course risk being
altered and perverted but what settles
the character of the deed is just this
whether the deed is an actual being that
endures or whether it is merely a fancy
performance that in itself is nothing at
all and passes away the analysis of this
being into intentions and subtleties of
that sort whereby the actual man that is
his deed is to be explained away again
in terms of a being that is only meant
just as the individual himself even may
create for himself special intentions
concerning his actuality all this must
be left to the laziness of mere
conjecture should this idle thinking
want to set its sterile wisdom to work
with the aim of denying the doer the
character of reason and so ill using him
as to declare that not as deed but its
face and lineaments are as real being
then it may expect to get the retort
spoken of above a retort which
demonstrates that the face or outward
appearance is not the individuals in
itself but on the contrary can be an
object for handling
Hagel begins and ends paragraph 322 by
bringing up some of lichten barracks
remarks lichtenberg had considered the
pseudoscience of physiognomies earlier
than Hagel and had drawn some negative
conclusions about it Hagel is going to
do this in a more systematic way so he
says lichtenberg says this if anyone
said you certainly act like an honest
man but I can see from your face that
you are forcing yourself to do so and
are a rogue at heart without a doubt
every honest fellow to the end of time
when when thus addressed will retort
with a box on the ear punching the guy
in the head and why so because something
fundamental about the human being is
being denied and what we're going to get
at is where the real being the vars sign
of the human being or sometimes in the
end passage just sign where does that
really reside this is a key question so
he says that if you know this this idle
thinking is at the very end wants to set
it sterile wisdom to work with the aim
of denying the doer the individual human
being the doer the person who's doing
things the character of reason and so
ill using him as to declare that not as
deed but his face and lineaments the way
in which he is put together the way in
which he appears bodily to other people
are you is real being then it may expect
to get the retort spoken of above a
retort that demonstrates that the face
or outward appearance is not the
individuals in itself but on the
contrary can be an object for handling
so what Hagel is doing here making a
very clever joke that works on two
levels it's you know sort of a beginning
and ending of the paragraph but it also
illustrates what the paragraph is
talking about if somebody wants to say
oh yeah I can tell what kind of person
you are I know exactly how you're going
to react and then you go up and you just
pop them one right I said were you
expecting that
you know there's there's something to
that what is that that punching the
other person right it is not simply the
passive way in which the body exists
it's very active they can see it's
reactive right you get angry at the
person you know and maybe if you have
you know the criminal cast that a lot of
people who are using this kind of
research were particularly interested oh
yeah I expected that of you but it would
still nonetheless stem from the person's
agency and freedom and agency and
freedom which is something we can
generalize about human beings at least
when it's experienced some freedom
doesn't like other people taking away
its freedom and showing it a fundamental
kind of disrespect so it responds as
lichtenberg says you know with a good
punch in the ear punching somebody on
the side of the head or maybe smacking
them you know that way so why is Hagel
saying let's put putting jokes aside and
funny images what is he after here he
says that we have to consider we're the
real being the virus sign the true being
of the person resides so he says what's
going on is we've got a science of mere
subjective opinion we've we've already
talked about this subjective opinion
being you know Lyris mine own intention
saying that something is is that way
asserting at drawing conclusions about
you know the person's appearance and
this so-called science this what we
nowadays call pseudoscience he has been
saying that the reality of a person is
their face or their clothing or their
skin color or the bones you know in in
their their skull or their genetics or
and we can go on and on and on and on
right so what can we draw from this
that's what physiognomies saying the
real being of the person consists in the
real being also you know what's inside
the person
but that's gotten two from this outside
so he says Hagel takes a different
position the true being of a person is
rather their deed they're taught what it
is that they do their action is another
way of translating this angle you know
goes back and forth in sometimes how he
discusses this in terms of several
different synonyms taught handle all
these verbs have to do with action with
practice with what a person commits
themselves to do it how they externalize
their own their own being so he says the
true being of a man is rather is deed in
this the individual is actual we only
become actual as individuals by doing
things in the world through the agency
of our bodies our bodies are how we
interact with the world you know Hagel
is an idealist but that does not mean
for a second that material things don't
exist it just means that they're also
encompassed by my spirit or mind and
he's going to talk here about a very
important aspect of this the the you
know universality of action so he says
it's the deed that does away with both
aspects of what is merely meant to be
again this mining opinion we can call it
meaning subjective opinion what-what two
aspects does it do away with so he says
the first is in the one aspect where
what is meant has the form of a
corporeal passive being right the bodily
appearance is what is meant by the
interior of the person going back to an
expression right the interior T of the
individual whatever that happens to be
their characteristics the traits you
know their mind they're their wishes or
wills their whims that's all somehow
supposed to be expressed in something
that we can see externally so you know
we think about this in terms of emotions
right I'm angry right now I can fake it
i like i just did a second ago maybe
that doesn't really reveal that much
about the person or you know I've been
you know told by some people that that
you know I look angry what I'm not angry
I know some people who when they're
thinking they look angry or sad or happy
when they're not feeling these emotions
at all and we can go further and further
and further like somebody you know maybe
somebody has a mouth that droops down
does that mean that there really an
unhappy person all the time because
they've you know they frown so much that
it's become part of their face no it
could be their facial muscles are set up
that way and so it really doesn't
signify what's within and focusing on
the action instead can allow us to draw
our eyes away from that subjective and
seductive misunderstanding of what the
person is is about what's the other one
he says the deed equally does away with
that in express ability of what is meant
in respect to the self conscious
individuality if people are expressing
oh you know there's something inside of
me and I just have to get it out you
know popular thing that we make fun of
in largely in movies strangely enough is
you know you're going to write the next
great american novel I've got a novel in
me no you you only have a novel in you
when it's actually coming out in writing
and then we can say you have a novel in
you know otherwise you just have a wish
to write a novel or some sort of batch
of ideas that you think somehow it might
be turned into a novel or screenplay
whatever you like right all these these
these things fall into the same sort of
category of the intention the mining to
be something to do something without
actually doing it so he goes on and he
says in such mere opinion the
individuality is infinitely determined
and determinable I should also point out
too that we take as he says a little bit
later on the bodily appearance
as providing the meaning of the deed so
we see somebody do something and then we
say oh well I think we have to interpret
it this way because they look like that
sort of person now what's going on there
is Hagel says we're taking the the
person as being infinitely determined
and determinable that sounds kind of
cool doesn't it oh you know infinitely
determine into determinable lot it's
like a feedback loop well really it
means totally arbitrary you can't tell
what's determining or what's determined
that anything can be anything you like
the only thing that's really determining
in that case is the outside observer
who's saying oh yeah i think that
persons are criminal or oh yeah i think
that that criminal is actually a good
guy I can tell by looking at him but he
didn't really mean to rape or kill or
steal he's probably a guy with good
intentions right we'll give him a light
sentence we have cases like this all the
time conversely oh yeah that guy is a
rough type I can tell that he's bad news
full sentence for him and let's see if
we can place him somewhere down state
away from his family we can go on and on
and on right haga wants to insist here
no it's the deed it's the action that
really tells us what a person is he says
in the accomplished deed this furious
infinity is destroyed this infinitely
determined and determinable we we do
away with that if we really do pay
attention to the deed if we focus on
that and we treat it the way it's
supposed to be treated no more it's up
to us now we get into the realm of the
more objective he says the deed is
something simply determined Universal
this is the key there the deed which is
an individual action carried out in a
specific circumstance by a particular
person is at the same time universal
Universal in a way
bodily appearance is not Universal
universal in a way that even in tier-ii
ority of the individual is not universal
this is where we see you know very
starkly Hagel's idealism is not an
idealism that somehow just privileges
mind over action privileges mind over a
room at ER it is one in which mind
permeates both and only shows itself
effectively in doing things in actually
taking Stan's now thinking can be a kind
of doing but somewhere along the line
it's got to connect up with the what we
call the real world or else it's as he
said earlier a false kind of idealism so
he goes on and he says he has some
examples a murder a theft or a good
action a brave deed and so on our water
what can be said of it we come back
again to the fact that language is what
permits us to speak in terms of
universals a good deed on my part is a
good deed and it can be a different good
deed than the good deed that you do but
we call them both good deed and we call
them based on what we actually see in
the deed they're subjective factors here
of course but you get the idea so he
says it is this and it's being is not
merely a sign but the fact itself it is
this and the individual human being is
what the deed is you find out what a
human being is through how they behave
not through their bodily appearance not
through something that you project back
into them as a criminal mentality you
want to know if they're a criminal
observe them see if they do criminal
actions and if you don't observe any
criminal actions maybe you should not
call them a criminal type maybe you have
to find another type so he goes on and
he says it in the simplicity of this
being the individual is for others a
universal being who really is and ceases
to be something only met this is very
important spirits
is not found as this spirit here this
spirit here the spirit here the spirit
here it is something wider than an
individual but it's comprised of
individuals in their relations to each
other through time in culture that's
what Hagel is ultimately aiming at in
this phenomenology of spirit it is
displayed in actions in deeds in doing
things in commitments in sacrifices in
prioritization in how these are
reproduced and that happens because of
the inherent universality of action so
he goes on and he says it's true that
the deed is not explicitly present as
spirit but when it is a question of his
being qua being and on the one hand the
twofold being of bodily shape indeed are
contrasted each purporting to be what he
actually is it is the deed alone that
must be affirmed is this genuine being
not his face that is outward appearance
which is supposed to express what he
means by his deeds so often we take
appearance as the cue for interpreting
what a person is doing and we just said
this already right this is where because
of its universality the locus of meaning
in a true sense ought to be found not
meaning in the sense of pure subjective
opinion or fancy or you know sort of
making stuff up as we go along and
calling it a science at least for the
time being until we prove it otherwise
so he goes on and he says here we go
similarly on the other hand where his
performance and his inner possibility
capacity or intention are contrasted
what are we talking about their
performance is there the performance is
what the deed does you might think also
the performance as being something that
goes beyond the deed it bears the traces
of it but it can also be what the deed
leaves behind we're going to come back
to that in a moment
but when we contrast that with the
interior T of the individual with what
he's called so far here in ER
possibility inner possibility infinitely
determined and determinable right when
people talk about inner possibilities
and they don't determine it in some way
that's just you know talk for I could be
anything I want to be capacity we have
capacities for think intentions
intentions seem to be you know what we
orient ourselves around I have the
intention to be a great philosopher and
someday give the lecture at this
university right well what will tell if
that's the case do I actually do the
work that would be required how do i act
do I just sit around in my armchair and
say Oh wouldn't that be nice well that's
not a real intention real intentions
show themselves in doing something and
we can say the same thing for loving we
can say the same thing for gratitude we
can say the same thing for opposing evil
you know we can go on and on about that
sort of thing so he says when we
contrast those it's the former that's to
be regarded as true actuality even if
the person deceives himself on that
point there's lots of people you know
Sartre will point this out later on but
he's just merely replicating what Hagel
is saying here people delude themselves
all the time about you know who they are
inside by contrast to who they show
themselves to be through their actions
sometimes there's that disconnect to
between the reactions and how they
physically appear to themselves to be so
he goes on and he says if the person
turns away from his action into himself
fancies that in his inner sun selfie is
something other than what he is in the
deed he's wrong about that into the Jew
allottee when it commits to the
objective element and putting itself
into a deep does in fact become
vulnerable it risks being altered and
perverted when you act that doesn't mean
that you don't act within a structural
system where your action might actually
get
turn into something quite different but
your action is still your action you do
what you do he says what settles the
character the deed is just this whether
the deed is an actual being that endures
this is again where we get to the
performance or work or whether it is a
merely fancy performance that is itself
nothing at all and passes away real
deeds significative who the person is
last they have a grouping within
realities well wait a second what about
people who died and they did great
things and everybody's forgotten them
well in a certain sense they haven't
been totally forgotten in this vast
repository process of spirit that's what
hegel would say I personally think that
that's that's not that that great of an
answer but that's that's a question that
can be left open at this point so he
goes on and he says the analysis of the
being into intentions and subtleties of
that sort whereby the actual man is to
be explained away again in terms of a
being that's only meant just as the
individual may create for himself
special intentions or concerning his
actuality all this must be left to the
laziness of mere conjecture and then we
get back to this this lichtenberg thing
in doing so we're not treating the other
individual person as a real individual
person who shows him or herself in their
action what if we want to express this
in one you know phrase we should take
actions more seriously than we do
declared intentions or appearances
you